now the police chief um i wanted to play
this for you too he's he's uh
uh giving his own briefing to the media
and here he is um talking about the
rioting
and having the the people in the media
the press try to convince him to his
face
that he didn't actually experience the
rioting that he personally experienced
let's listen
what what led to you to issue a
dispersal order and then on the back end
of that 10-minute dispersal order
then to issue out co2 canisters and gas
for the crowd yeah just so everybody's
clear i was
fronting front and center at the protest
at the
at the riot um we did not
do that so
i was we were being the officers that
were putting themselves in harm's way
were being pelted with frozen cans a pop
they were being belted with concrete
blocks and yes we had our helmets on
and we had other protection gear but an
officer was injured
hit in the head with a brick that was a
hennepin county deputy
he was transported to the hospital so we
had to make decisions we had to disperse
the crowd because we can allow
our officers to be harmed and i've
already answered the question i believe
about your lighting
i know that's a that's a big deal with
you and i understand that but i thought
i'd explain that myself so that is
i told you it's my decision and that's
why i made that decision
there was no rioting you could almost
imagine them like a cartoon they've got
the pocket watch out
and they're hypnotizing him and they're
hoping that he has little you know
swirls in his eyes there was no rioting
there was no rioting um
no there was he he was just there his
officers were hit in the head with
bricks
there were buildings burned down we just
saw the footage of looting that's going
on i mean
it it it feels fruitless and pointless
to to even
point out when the media is lying but
what else are we going to do but point
it out let them do it and
and and not even make the observation
but the lying here is so brazen
i i hate to keep using the term
orwellian it's so overused but it but
in this case i there's no other term
that applies
as well as that term does where they
are lying to you about what you are
seeing
with your own eyes and telling you that
you're not seeing what you're seeing
there was no writing it's it's not even
like they won't even do us the favor
they're insulting our intelligence so
much that they think they can
tell us that there was no rioting at all
rather than
a slightly more plausible lie or you
know
taking the approach of saying yeah there
was writing but it's justified for this
and that reason
that is also insane and stupid and wrong
but at least you're acknowledging
some of the reality in that case now as
it happens from the left we actually get
both of those things
on one hand they tell us that there's no
writing on the other hand they tell us
that
uh well if there is writing it it's
justified it it's not it doesn't exist
but if it does exist then it's here's
why it's justified
trying to play play both ends of it
there listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated